hi everyone we have some exciting news
over the last 12 months it's gotten
incredibly busy here we are shooting we
are editing we are doing tons of stuff
we are making more videos than we ever
have before and we are running into
bottlenecks and we need your help so if
you are a professional editor and you
want to work in this crazy environment
that we call corridor digital trust me
it's actually not that crazy when the
camera's not rolling we're all just
grinding away you'll cut that part
with editing yeah then we would like for
you to apply to work here at quarter
digital how do i apply you may ask well
it's really simple basically in the
description we have included a link to a
bunch of clips from an unreleased video
and we want you to edit them with your
style once you've done that send us a
link to that video following our very
strict formatting instructions format it
this way in the subject line put
corridor job application followed by
vertical line followed by your name and
then in the body of the email put your
name again with an unlisted youtube link
and that's it when all the emails will
look the same all we're gonna do is just
judge you by how good your video is
please format and send this email
correctly we're gonna get hundreds and
hundreds of these emails if you guys
don't format the email correctly is real
simple
i'm probably not going to watch the
video because you didn't format the
email correctly and
one small note you might not be aware of
this but our studio is currently located
in los angeles california so if you do
happen to be selected as an applicant
you might have to move here applications
will end at the end of day on march 15th
pacific time i'll be looking for all of
your beautifully formatted emails with
your incredible edits
we will announce when we have found
somebody follow us on twitter or
instagram or obviously on the channels
and we'll do updates as we as we move
through the process thank you for
listening to our video and if you are
considering applying thank you for
putting in the time for the application
i know editing can be a lot of work we
are flattered with every single
application that comes in it means a lot
to us honestly
and that's when you cut away from me
editing editing so see what the problem
right now is this video is not being
edited
[Music]
cut the clip cut the dang clip
something cut
don't just i just want to record on a
vhs tape and it's less
[Music]
[Music]
you